meet Zen he has given eight algebra
tests this year and these are his scores
in the first test he scored a 78 in the
second one he scored an 80 and 82 in the
third and so on so one day Zara asks him
about his performance in algebra now Zen
has two options he can either tell Zara
about his score in each test something
like in the first test I scored a 78 in
the second test I scored an 80 in the
third I scored
82 and the other option Zen has is to
tell his average score over the period
so he tells Zara that he scored around
8081 in the previous
year here Zen just approximately
averaged his score over the period to
give Zara an idea about his
performance this is far more convenient
as compared to many mentioning the score
in each of his
tests now let's see how we actually find
the
average consider these five numbers 1 3
8 12 and 16 there is a very simple way
in which the average can be
calculated it can be calculated as sum
of values divided by the number of
values that's how simple it is to find
the average look at the numerator first
the sum of the values
some of these values would equal 1 + 3 +
8 + 12 + 16 and how many values do we
have here 1 2 3 4 and five five values
we divide the numerator by 5 1 + 3 is 4
4 + 8 is 12 12 + 12 is 24 and 24 + 16 is
40 so the average would equal 40 by 5
which equals
8 this is the average of the five
numbers in the list the average is also
called the mean or to be more precise
the arithmetic
[Music]
mean